und jetzt das heute journal
mit heinz wolf und marietta slomka
würden abends der mord am cdu politiker
walter lübke hat die gefahr die
hierzulande von rechtsextremen ausgeht
überdeutlich gemacht
nicht dass man das nicht auch schon seit
dem terror des nsu hätte wissen können
immerhin wurde im verlaufe offenbar
schnell in die richtige richtung
geleitet
umso bestürzender ist es dass die
bundesanwaltschaft ihre ermittlungen
gegen den festgenommenen tatverdächtigen
nun ausweitet es gibt den verdacht dass
der polizeibekannte neonazi bereits 2016
versucht hat einen menschen zu ermorden
susanne santina berichtet der
heimtückische mord versucht blieb damals
ungeklärt von hinten nähert sich ein
mann und sticht einem irakischen
asylbewerber brutal mit einem messer in
den rücken
das opfer wird schwer verletzt überlebt
nur knapp
in der nähe des tatorts wohnt stephanie
gegen den die bundesanwaltschaft nun
auch wegen dieser tat ermittelt der
hauptverdächtige mordfall walter lübke
soll also versucht haben einen weiteren
mann zu töten und die bundesanwaltschaft
geht davon aus dass stefan s
rechtsextremistische gesinnung
ausschlaggebend gewesen seien seien
mutmaßlichen mordversuch an einem iraker
erst vor drei jahren wirft fragen auf
warum ernst aus dem fokus der behörden
hier in hessen geraten ist seit 2010 wir
können das nicht nachvollziehen und
alles was jetzt zusätzlich rauskommt
dann informationen bestätigt uns darin
dass wir nicht nachvollziehen können
warum die behörden aufgehört haben ihn
zu beobachten
auch markus harder mann der stephanie
die tatwaffe vermittelt haben soll oder
offenbar von den sicherheitsbehörden in
seiner gefährlichkeit unterschätzt er
war genauso wie stefan mitglied in
diesem schützenverein und er hielt 2015
legal eine waffenbesitzkarte und 2011
einen sprengstoff berechtigungsschein
obwohl er als neonazi und der andere mit
hitlergruß und sieg heil -rufen
aufgefallen war auch gegen markus h
ermittelt die bundesanwaltschaft
und glaubt nun dass er dem mutmaßlichen
mörder stephanie psychische beihilfe
geleistet hat der beschuldigte bestärkte
mit hoher wahrscheinlichkeit dessen
entschluss den mordanschlag auf dr lücke
tatsächlich auszuführen
die neonazis stefan
und markus h waren befreundet besuchten
nach erkenntnissen der
bundesanwaltschaft auch zusammen die
veranstaltung in lohfelden die walter
lübke wegen seiner worte an asyl
kritiker zum hassobjekt der rechten
szene machte markus h soll diese szene
gefilmt und ins netz gestellt haben
da muss aufgewertet werden und wenn sie
mehr gewicht und markus hahn stephanie
arbeiteten zeitweise in der gleichen
firma auf dessen gelände die tatwaffe
gefunden wurde und in der ein weiterer
freund tätig war
er soll waffen von stefanie gekauft
haben gegen ihn wurde auch ein
ermittlungsverfahren eröffnet und zwar
nach paragraf 89a das heißt schwere
staatsgefährdende straftat und das wäre
sozusagen möglicherweise die dritte
person die dann dazu führt dass auch der
generalbundesanwalt hier sagen davon
sprechen kann dass es sich hier um eine
terroristische vereinigung handelt die
theorie dass stefan er als einzeltäter
gehandelt hat wird immer
unwahrscheinlicher
und immer mehr drängt sich auch die
frage auf warum stephanie seit diesem
angriff von rechtsradikalen auf eine dgb
demo in dortmund wo erkennungsdienstlich
behandelt wurde vom radar der
sicherheitsbehörden verschwand sieben
jahre später nach dem mutmaßlichen
mordversuch an dem irak in lohfelden
wurde auch stephanie von der polizei
überprüft folgen hat es damals keine für
den neonazi
es ist unglaublich dass man sich für die
rettung von menschen vor dem ertrinken
rechtfertigen muss dieser satz stammt
nicht von rettungsschiff kapitänin
carola rakete sondern von
bundesinnenminister horst seehofer dem
heute in berlin deutlich anzumerken war
wie sehr er sich über die kritik aus
seiner eigenen partei erkannt seine
parteifreundin gab er dann noch ein mit
indem er darauf hinwies er sei mitglied
einer christlichen partei die den
kurswechsel ihres ehemaligen parteichefs
allerdings noch nicht durchweg
nachvollzogen hat
kritik gibt es vor allem an seehofers
bereitschaft ein viertel der vor italien
aus seenot geretteten flüchtlinge
aufzunehmen
frank buchwald bericht
sie kommen aus libyen sie hoffen auf
europa bootsflüchtlinge im mittelmeer
aufgenommen oft von deutschen
hilfsorganisationen
ihr schicksal bisher jedoch meist unklar
nun aber will deutschland ein viertel
der geretteten aufnehmen eine
entscheidung die innenminister seehofer
heute vehement verteidigt ich weise die
kritik an diesem verfahren aufs
schärfste zurück es ist unglaublich dass
man sich als bundesinnenminister für die
rettung von menschen vor dem ertrinken
rechtfertigen muss ein bemerkenswerter
satz denn auf dem höhepunkt der
flüchtlingskrise im herbst 2015 hatte
seehofer damals csu-chef die kanzlerin
für ihre politik der offenen grenzen
hart kritisiert sprach gar von
herrschaft des unrechts sein heutiger
satz klingt fast wie merkel im september
vor vier jahren
ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen wenn wir
jetzt anfangen uns noch entschuldigen zu
müssen dafür dass wir in notsituationen
ein freundliches gesicht zeigen dann ist
das nicht mein land andere zeiten neue
gesichter kloster banz oberfranken wie
das seine cdu chefin zu gast bei der csu
heute aber klingt der sound aus dem
süden viel persönlicher humanität ist
selbstverständlich ergibt sich bei uns
aus dem ursprung auch unsere parteien
gründung als christliche parteien und
umgekehrt ist auch wichtig dass darüber
die ordnung erhalten bleibt eine ordnung
die aus sicht der union allerdings nur
in einer europäischen gesamtlösung
bestehen kann
eine lösung die vor allen dingen auch
deutlich macht dass wir nicht das
geschäft derjenigen betreiben die
sozialen aus den herkunftsländern oder
an den küsten menschen ganz bewusst in
lebensgefahr setzen nämlich das geschäft
der schlepper zu betreiben das ist die
hohe kunst ein signal vor allem an die
kritiker von seehofers vorschlag etwa
der mächtige chef der
csu-landtagsfraktion
es ist eine zahl von menschen wir wissen
ja nicht was 25 prozent für kritik auch
von thüringens cdu chef mohring er muss
in ein paar wochen den landtagswahlen
bestehen und hat die afd im genick
damit wird ihr neuer anreiz geschaffen
werden und der ist jedenfalls nicht
richtig ängste die einst auch seehofer
umgetrieben haben aktuell aber so
beschwichtigt der minister gehe es um
ganz andere zahlen
wir reden über 225 bei insgesamt
wahrscheinlich 150000 im ganzen jahr
und wichtiger noch die verteilung von
flüchtlingen innerhalb europas steht
wieder auf der tagesordnung
und während sich horst seehofer für
einen humanen umgang mit
bootsflüchtlingen start macht entdeckt
markus söder den klimaschutz aktivisten
in sich so fordert der bayerische
ministerpräsident den klimaschutz ins
grundgesetz aufzunehmen und will dass
bayern bis 2040 klimaneutral wird
doch nicht nur söder hat erkannt dass
der klimawandel ein thema ist das große
teil der bevölkerung und treibt nicht
nur in der jungen generation und dazu
beiträgt dass die grünen von einem
umfragehoch zum nächsten sprang
die bundesregierung will morgen über ihr
klima paket entscheiden heute abend tagt
dazu das spitzenpersonal von union und
spd im koalitionsausschuss aus berlin
cornelia schiemenz es ist die k frage um
die sich heute nacht im kanzleramt alles
dreht die klimafrage wird zur
bewährungsprobe der großen koalition
es gibt da einen gemeinsamen geist wir
wollen das jetzt umsetzen und das ist
ambitioniert und für uns ist natürlich
wichtig dass wir jetzt den kohleausstieg
nochmal gesetzlich regeln dass wir beim
ausbau der erneuerbaren voran kommt dass
wir co2 mindern dass wir wirklich auch
ganz klar zur einsparung co2 bereich
kommen 55 prozent seines
treibhausgasausstoßes muss deutschland
bis 2030 einsparen ein fast illusorisch
es ziel
es gilt die bürger dabei mitzunehmen sie
zu belasten und gleichzeitig zu
entlasten die wirtschaft zu fordern und
gleichzeitig zu fördern das ist die
herausforderung dieser nacht in berlin
wir wollen gerade durch die maßnahmen
die wir jetzt auch beraten dafür sorgen
dass unsere wirtschaft auch mit blick
auf neue entwicklungen neue forschungen
innovationen auch im internationalen
wettbewerb wettbewerbsfähigkeit zum
zweiten müssen wir wirklich schauen dass
wir für alle menschen klimaschutz als
positives signal sehen
monatelang wurde gerechnet verhandelt
und letztlich doch wieder verworfen aus
diesem entwurf müssen die
koalitionsspitzen jetzt das klima paket
schnüren so viel scheint sicher eine co2
steuer kommt wohl nicht durch den handel
mit verschmutzungsrechten wird es
trotzdem teurer
erneuerbare energien werden ausgebaut
gebäudesanierungen steuerlich gefördert
bahntickets werden billiger und
billigflüge teurer für die
umweltverbände und die opposition nicht
der große wurf nach allem was man bis
jetzt an daten sieht man weiß ja nicht
genau was am ende beschlossen ist
besteht keine chance dass mit den
maßnahmen die 2030 ziele eingehalten
werden
trotz aller bekenntnisse im vorfeld hier
im kanzleramt wird es in diesen stunden
hoch hergehen
zu viele fragen sind noch offen in
berlin rechnet man mit einer langen
nacht eine lange nacht
gunther love energy an welchen stellen
hakt den moment besonders also wir haben
ja heute einen entwurf gesehen des
klimaschutz papieres was die koalition
hier berät dass es zwar stand
montagabend gewesen seitdem wird sich
noch ein bisschen was getan haben aber
die liste der offenen fragen die ist da
doch so lang dass man sich fragen muss
ob es sich überhaupt lohnt einen
herauszuheben
ein ganz wesentlicher punkt ist
sicherlich die frage wie macht man co2
emissionshandel oder co2 steuer eine
andere frage ist die wie viel das ganze
am ende kosten wird nicht nur für die
ausgleichszahlungen die man machen
möchte um die folgen abzumildern sondern
auch für innovationen
da sagt das papier das war es brauche
mindestens eine zusätzliche dreistellige
milliardensumme alleine für
klimafreundliche innovationen aber
unterm strich wird es darauf ankommen
dass das gesamtpaket schlüssig ist wenn
die große koalition hat ja hier vor den
klimaschutz mit wirtschaftswachstum und
mit sozialverträglichkeit zu versöhnen
und sie weiß offensichtlich dass die
aufgabe so groß ist dass sie
vorsichtshalber in das papier ein
geschrieben hat das sei eine
gesamtgesellschaftliche aufgabe
das ist die vorbereitung auf den großen
wurf die frage ist nur ob er denn kommt
und sollen ja morgen schon ergebnisse
vorliegen also man will sich ja doch
schon auch entschlossen zeigen ja das
will man auf jeden fall das konnte man
heute auch schon an den statements
höheren annegret kramp karrenbauer hat
gesagt das was hier in den nächsten 24
stunden geschlossen werde
das müsste doch mindestens mal die
nächsten 24 jahre halten und je
konkreter das ist was hier beschlossen
wird desto besser und desto schneller
wird es gehen dass da auch was
langfristig ist dabei rauskommt aber
dass es eben die große frage wie konkret
wird die große koalition in ihrem
vorhaben da geht es im großen wie im
kleinen um viele details die umstritten
sind
man hat sich vorgenommen das ganze bis
morgen mittag zu besprechen wir hören
auch das schon erste pressekonferenz
termine für morgen mittag diskutiert
werden dass ich aber keiner wirklich
sicher ist ob die so zu halten ist und
dankeschön nach berlin
und jetzt mache ich erstmal weiter ein
bluttest für schwangere zur gehen
untersuchung des werdenden kindes soll
künftig in begründeten einzelfällen von
der krankenkasse bezahlt werden das hat
das spitzengremium aus ärzten kliniken
und kassen entschieden
der test untersuchte am blut der
schwangeren ob das kind eine bestimmte
form der trisomie etwa das down syndrom
hat das kann die riskantere
fruchtwasseruntersuchungen ersetzen die
von den krankenkassen bereits bezahlt
wird in brandenburg könnte es zu einer
rot schwarz grünen regierung kommen
zweieinhalb wochen nach der landtagswahl
hat ministerpräsident dietmar woidke dem
spd-landesvorstand
koalitionsverhandlungen mit cdu und
grünen vorgeschlagen auch die
landesspitzen von cdu und grünen
berieten über die aufnahme von
koalitionsverhandlungen
bei den grünen fällt die entscheidung
bei einem kleinen parteitag am samstag
im landtag hätte er rot schwarz grün
eine mehrheit von sechs stimmen die
grünen politikerin renate künast wehrt
sich gegen eine entscheidung des
berliner landgerichts sie wollte wegen
beschimpfungen auf einer digitalen
plattform die personenbezogenen daten
von 22 nutzern das gericht lehnte ab mit
der begründung die äußerungen seien hier
im zusammenhang mit einer pädophilie
debatte gefallen
sie seien noch als zulässige
meinungsäußerung zu werten und stellten
keine straftaten gab
hintergrund sind kommentare zu einem
zeitungsbericht über einen vorgang von
1986 im berliner abgeordnetenhaus im
zusammenhang mit der damalige pädophilie
debatte bei den grünen
mehr zu diesem thema finden sie auch auf
heute.de
irans außenminister rief hat erneut eine
verantwortung für den anschlag auf die
höhle anlage in saudi arabien
zurückgewiesen und die usa und saudi
arabien vor einem militärschlag gegen
sein land gewarnt
tariq sagte in einem interview mit dem
us sender cnn
ein angriff in irgendeiner form werde zu
einem umfassenden krieg führen
us-außenminister pompeo beschuldigte bei
einem besuch in den vereinigten
arabischen emiraten erneut die führung
in teheran erklärte aber auch dass die
usa den konflikt mit iran friedlich
lösen wollten nach der parlamentswahl in
israel geht angesichts der pattsituation
das tauziehen um die künftige führung im
land weiter der bisherige
ministerpräsident netanjahu räumte ein
dass nach den ergebnissen die von ihm
versprochene regierung nicht möglich sei
und erfordert zu seinen stärksten
konkurrenten benny gantz vom
oppositionellen bündnis blau-weiß auf
eine einheitsregierung zu bilden
auch ganz sprach sich für eine
einheitsregierung aus aber erforderte
unter seiner führung
tunesiens ex präsident ben ali ist tot
wie sein anwalt bestätigte starb er im
alter von 83 jahren im exil in saudi
arabien
ben ali hatte tunesien mehr als 20
jahren regiert er galt zunächst als
modernisierer und reformer regierte aber
zunehmend autoritär 2011 verließ er nach
wochenlangen protesten gegen das regime
sein land damit war er der erste
machthaber der im sogenannten arabischen
frühlings gestürzt wurde war der
attentäter vom berliner breitscheidplatz
tatsächlich ein einzeltäter oder hatte
er komplett diese frage beschäftigt auch
den bundestags untersuchungsausschuss
zum fall ambri bundesinnenministerium
und sicherheitsbehörden vertreten
vehement die einzeltäterthese amri
plante und handelte allein
doch daran gibt es große zweifel fdp
grüne und linke haben im ausschuss jetzt
gemeinsam einen antrag eingereicht der
dem zdf vorliegt sie fordern dass ein
freund des attentäters als zeuge geladen
wird
florian hat berichtet bislang kaum
bekannte bilder die überwachungskamera
vom hochhaus gegenüber schwenkt über
berlin
da erfasst sie einen lastwagen der in
den weihnachtsmarkt rast
breitscheidplatz neunzehnter dezember
2016 mit einem lkw reist anis amri elf
menschen in den tod
und so langsam reißt manchem der die tat
aufklären will
der geduldsfaden etwa im
untersuchungsausschuss des bundestags
der akten zum umfeld des attentäters
lesen will vom verfassungsschutz und der
stattdessen vor wenigen tagen dieses
schreiben erhält aus dem
innenministerium eine verzögerung
anzeige
leider könne man die akten wegen
überlastung nicht fristgerecht liefern
vertröstet wird für einen teil auf
januar 2021 ein schlechter witz sagen
abgeordnete aus opposition und koalition
der untersuchungsausschuss muss
bis zum ende der legislaturperiode die
arbeit abgeschlossen haben
deswegen ist eine akten vorlage erst im
jahr 2021 natürlich nicht sehr sinnvoll
das ist völlig inakzeptabel wir müssen
die akten jetzt haben wir müssen sie
jetzt einsehen können damit wir jetzt
auch zeugen in dieser sache vernehmen
können
zeugen die bei der aufklärung einer der
wichtigsten fragen helfen könnten
handelte ambri wirklich allein so wie es
sicherheitsbehörden und bundesregierung
bis heute vertreten bleiben sie bei der
these dass amys ambri
bei dem anschlag auf dem
breitscheidplatz als einzeltäter
gehandelt hat aus unserer sicht gibt es
hierzu keinen neuen stand kein neuer
stand aber zahlreiche hinweise die gegen
die geschichte vom einsamen wolf
sprechen
diese these ist mehrfach bereits
widerlegt worden und je näher wir der
these kommen desto höher ist die
blockadehaltung der bundesregierung nun
wagen fdp linke und grüne einen neuen
anlauf sie wollen einen der engsten
kontakt leute von ambri vor den
untersuchungsausschuss laden den
franzosen clément mit ihm und einem
dritten islamisten marco metall ic
plante ambri offenbar schon im oktober
2016 an den anschlag auf das berliner
gesundbrunnen center als ambri später
sondern lkw anschlag plante schrieb
erklimmen b wohl immer wieder etwa zwei
tage vor der tat
wo bist du wo bist du bruder wir müssen
uns schnell sehen
das geht hervor aus der anklageschrift
dem prozess um die anschlagspläne auf
das gesundbrunnen center die dem zdf
ebenfalls vorliegt eines amri warte
kontakt zu top-terroristen wir wollen
diese top-terroristen hören um das
netzwerk aufzuklären wer wusste alles
von den anschlagsplanungen am
breitscheidplatz gab es weitere mittäter
derzeit sitzt clément b in frankreich in
haft
auch die vertreter von union und spd
sagen heute einen versuch sei es wert
sie wollen seine vorladung vor den
ausschuss unterstützen
empörung und enttäuschung heute in tokio
alle sind unschuldig ein ungerechtes
urteil so steht es auf den protest
denn heute endete der erste strafprozess
zur atomkatastrophe von fukushima mit
einem freispruch für drei top-manager
der betreiberfirma tepco
das gericht vertrat die ansicht die
manager hätten damals weder das tsunami
risiko unterschätzt noch nötigen
sicherheitsmassnahmen unterlassen
zur erinnerung 2011 hatte infolge eines
schweren seebebens eine 16 meter hohe
flutwelle das atomkraftwerk überspült an
dem im nachhinein dann auch noch große
sicherheitsmängel festgestellt wurden
vor allem war es nicht ausreichend vor
überschwemmungen geschützt und in die
ruine dringt nach wie vor wasser ein
grundwasser das in der anlage
kontaminiert wird mit pumpen müssen
täglich bis zu 150 tonnen wasser
abgesaugt und gesammelt werden
doch die lagertanks sind mittlerweile
voll und es gibt kaum noch platz für
neue die firma tepco überlegt deshalb
sogar solch verseuchtes wasser
mittelfristig ins meer abzuleiten
die lieblosigkeit nach dem unglück ist
also weiterhin groß auch bei den
bewohnern der region
achteinhalb jahre danach stefan die
schöne bauen berichtet von dort
sie sind eine kleine gruppe freiwilliger
die regelmäßig in fukushimas wäldern die
radioaktivität messen
sie trauen der regierung nicht die sagt
dass man beruhigt wieder hierhin ziehen
kann
rund um fukushima das alles gut sei die
behaupten ja immer so sachen wie dass
die strahlung nicht wandert aber durch
wind und regen wandert die
radioaktivität doch wenn man hier vor
ort misst bekommt man schnell mit dass
zum beispiel dort wo eine pfütze ist der
wert fiel höher ist
an vielen orten wohnen wieder menschen
sie sind zurückgekehrt nicht in die
eigenen häuser aber zumindest in der
region
denn die regierung hat mittlerweile
viele orte freigegeben
zahlreiche häuser und gegenden werden
dekontaminiert die wälder nicht hier
bleibt alles wie es ist und die
messwerte sind bei weitem nicht
eindeutig an manchen stellen werden 1,2
mikrosievert pro stunde gemessen was
extrem belastend und doppelt so hoch wie
der grenzwert in japan ist das sind ja
die werte in der umgebung von
messstationen
aber wenn man nur fünf meter von so
einer messstation weiter misst dann
kommen ganz andere werte heraus das hat
mir damals schon freunde erzählt und
meine entdeckung war das so stimmt die
realität war ganz anders
und weil sie kritisch ist ist tomoko
sato auch extra nach tokio gekommen
sie wartet auf das urteil für einen
prozess der überhaupt erst auf ihren
druck den der bürger zustande kam und
das gericht hat entschieden
freispruch für die drei früheren top
manager des japanischen
kraftwerksbetreibers tepco
die menschen hier sind enttäuscht und
wütend in sprechchören riefen sie
wir werden diese ungerechtigkeit nicht
hin
das ist wirklich unglaublich das ist ein
unglaubliches urteil was passiert nun
mit unserem jahrgang ist doch es ist
wirklich erschreckend
berufliche fahrlässigkeit mit todesfolge
so lautete die anklage
der vorwurf die top-manager sollen schon
2008 gewusst haben dass in fukushima ein
tsunami drohte der eine höhe von knapp
16 meter erreichen könnte und somit den
vorhandenen schutzwall weit übersteigen
würde
sie hätten gewusst dass es zu einem
stromausfall und somit so einer atom
katastrophe kommen könnte ich habe jetzt
erst verstanden dass das urteil nicht
für die menschen die anwohner gesprochen
wurde
menschen leben wurden hier nicht
berücksichtigt dafür aber wurden firmen
und die wirtschaftlichen interessen
vorgezogen
tomoko sagt uns dass sie weiter kämpfen
wird die bürger japans werden in
berufung gehen gerechtigkeit fordern mit
oder ohne gericht die urteilsbegründung
dass der tsunami und die atomkatastrophe
nicht vorhersehbar gewesen sein
reichen ihm nicht und jetzt nochmal eins
zunächst mit wirtschaft baureihen er war
heute hauptversammlung in dublin
da ging es unter anderem um das künftige
flugangebot um stellenstreichungen und
war der reale auch um ein bonusprogramm
ja und zwar für ryanair chef o'leary
sein üppiges gehalt das steht ja schon
lange in der kritik aber dieses mal
machten aktionäre ihrem ärger schon
besonders deutlich luft schließlich ist
das bonuspaket auch nach internationalen
maßstab gigantisch lässt sich so kennt
man ryanair chef o'leary nur mit
hauchdünner mehrheit bekam er von den
aktionären grünes licht für seinen
monster bonus 99 millionen euro wenn die
geschäfte in den kommenden fünf jahren
gut laufen
der bonus dürfte auch ryanair
mitarbeitern übel aufstoßen
die airline plant bis zu 700 stellen zu
streichen
grund sei das flugverbot von boeing 737
max wodurch der airline bestellte
flieger fehlen
auch sonst gibt es baustellen die
gewinne sinken außerdem streiken seit
über einem jahr mitarbeiter tausende
flüge mussten gestrichen werden am ende
stimmte ryanair zähneknirschend in
mehreren ländern gesprächen mit
gewerkschaften zu seitdem sinken aber
auch aktienkurs und gewinn um ein
viertel hat der kurs verloren in den
vergangenen zwölf monaten in deutschland
ist die irische billigfluglinie schon
auf dem rückzug hat innerdeutsche flüge
komplett gestrichen airlines liefern
sich eben in ganz europa einen ruinösen
preiskampf die billig masche können sie
sich aber kaum mehr leisten
valerie haller vielen dank
für eintracht frankfurt hat am abend die
europa league gruppenphase mit einer
niederlage begonnen zu hause gegen den
fc arsenal frankfurt hat 0 zu 3 verloren
die zielvorgabe von eintracht trainer
adi hütter sind auch gegen den
ruhmreichen fc arsenal aus london ganz
klar zu hause drei punkte und sein team
kann sich vor allem über links mit einem
sehr starken philipp kostet einige
gefährliche möglichkeiten erspielen
in einer ausgeglichenen partie dauert
ist ziemlich genau 38 minuten bis zum
ersten treffer den mittelfeldspieler joe
blob mit einem unhaltbar abgefälschten
schuss für sich verbuchen kann
nach der halbzeit zunächst das gleiche
bild zahlreiche chancen auf beiden
seiten
hierfür frankfurt vergeben durch den
unglücklichen neuzugang andre silber in
der 78 minute volk spiel entscheidendes
als domenico mit gelb rot den platz
verlassen muss die engländer gegen zehn
erschöpfte frankfurter fortan klar
überlegen sturm massaker in der 85
minute mit dem 2 0
und nur drei minuten später der ex
torben der oberhammer jan mit dem
schlusspunkt dem 3 zu 0 für den fc basel
der das frankfurter gruppenphasen debüt
überraschend deutlich missraten lässt
was hat uns gleich gehts bei maybrit
illner weiter die mit ihren gästen über
das klima paket der bundesregierung
debattiert und daniel bröckerhoff meldet
sich dann um 00 35 mit heute clubs bis
morgen auf der sehen
[Musik]
mit am liebe zuschauer hoher luftdruck
bringt uns jetzt eigentlich ruhiges
herbstwetter ein hochdruckgebiet
verlagert sich langsam zu uns von
großbritannien zieht es genau nach
mitteleuropa rein und deshalb kommen wir
an die westseite und das bedeutet es
wird langsam in den nächsten tagen aus
südwesten wieder ein bisschen wärme
allerdings morgen auch ein paar dichtere
wolken an der küste kann es auch hier
und da ein bisschen regnen die
temperaturen steigen ein bisschen schon
morgen also im westen erreichen wir 20
grad sonst bleibt es kühler
im osten noch und so richtig frisch ist
es ja im norden von skandinavien
tagsüber fünf bis zehn grad nachts bis
minus 5 grad
und so kalt kann es auch bei uns werden
nicht ganz so kalt minus zwei grad
vielleicht kannst das im östlichen
bayern geben sonst aber müssen sie mit
bodenfrost rechnen in der mitte und auch
im süden während es im norden doch
deutlich milder ist es ist meist klar in
dieser nacht erst in der zweiten
nachthälfte wird es an den küsten
bewölkter morgen früh könnte seiner nord
sich schon mal kleiner regenschauer
geben
die ziehen tagsüber dann weiter über das
küstengebiet nach osten zur ostsee
vielleicht erreichen sie auch mal
brandenburg und berlin bei diesem
kräftigen west bis nordwestwind in der
mitte und im süden ändert sich nichts
gegenüber heute da wird es überwiegend
sonnig und wir haben diesen mäßigem
ostwind dazu aber die temperaturen am
rhein die steige nebenan 19 bis 22 grad
können wir dort erwarten sonst bleibt es
ähnlich wie heute 15 bis 17 grad mild
aber es wird wärmer zum wochenende und
dazu wird auch überwiegend sonnig sein
ob samstag oder sonntag und erst in der
neuen woche wird es wechselhaft von
westen und langsam etwas kühler
ich wünschen noch einen schönen abend
machen sie es gut